there was actually a funny moment over
the weekend and we're gonna move past
this where it was Michigan's interterm
coach and I tweeted about this
um and it was his interview uh shiron
Moore after the
game uh say that this has been a crazy
24 hours for your guys to win on the
road in this environment when there were
doubts sh what does it mean to
you want I thank the Lord want I thank
Coach Harbaugh
love you man love the out
of you man this for you but this
University the president our ad we got
the best players best university best
alumni in the country love you guys
these guys right here these guys
right here man these guys did it these
guys did it man talk to him man love
you I mean my thoughts are right I
thought it was a little funny um but you
know that that's the that's the love and
passion we love to see for the game you
could tell this guy truly cares about uh
the kids he worked for you tell you
could tell he cares about the university
uh he's grateful for his opportunity and
it's not often uh you know young men
like him get an opportunity to coach so
you know he's he's getting and he went
to a hostile environment he went there
and beat my NY lions and and that's hard
to do and you
know we just all thought was dragged
because it it almost seemed like you
know Harbaugh had passed away or
something like that if you ain't know
better you just saw that interview um
you know you you would think something
was what happened to John Harbor I think
that's why a lot of people's uh
reactions was that um but you know I
thought it was a great interview um I
don't think there's nothing wrong with
anything that he said um I just thought
you know a lot of people might have
thought it was a little dramatic but you
love to see that passion you love to see
everything he's bringing to the game um
what are my thoughts about Sidelines uh
hard ball suspension I mean I honestly
hate that type of suspension uh I think
you should just finding school or
something like that uh to take away a
head coach someone that they love
playing for someone they that they love
having around um taking him on the
sideline so he can't coach him that's
that's tough and then say he can only
coach during the week I mean there's a
lot goes into that you know I think a
lot of players look to to their coaches
in times and um when it comes to time
management game management situations um
where hard bgh does the best uh so I I
hate that type of suspension um and he
said they should Michigan should be
America's team now that's something I
disagree with America's team should
always be Penn State after all the
adversity and things that Penn State
been through we should be America's team
um I don't agree with that Michigan has
always you know they they can never be
America's team especially after Ohio
State's dominance over the last you know
decade or so guess they have been
winning the last two years um but we
cannot just start America's team like
that thoughts on all the Michigan
players um you know I and you know it's
tough for the Michigan players you see
the reaction they all tweeting bet
they're they're feeling emotional even
Tom Brady joined in obviously it's more
it's always more than
just you know the player is is that
player coach relationship is so
important and and you just hate to see
that you know and I just don't agree and
you know it it's
wrong